I reached five years and my oncologist took me off the horrible blocker at Astrosol.
I have been off it for about a week, should I get retested?
And I think the person saying, should I get to do another cheek swab test?
Maybe not.
So if you're on a horrible blocky therapy, so if you have a positive ER positive or hurtful positive cancer,
typically, they're going to put you on an enromatase inhibitor that's going to block all your hormones.
If you reach a certain point, I mean, I'm surprised that they're taking you off after five years,
and the oncologist will keep people on for ten years now.
It used to be much shorter than five years that they would keep you on.
But now, I guess the rule of thumb, at least for that oncologist's office, is to take you off if you've got a clean meal of health.
That five years, first of all, congratulations for that.
Give God the praise for healing you and keeping you in a healed state.
Now we want to keep you in that healed state as much as possible doing our part, right?
If you have a horrible positive cancer and they take you off of the horrible blocker,
I would definitely go on a natural aerobotase inhibitor for sure.
Do we need to do a cheek swab test for that?
Not necessarily.
Honestly, I would just go on a roba clear.
That's our most balanced or natural aerobotase inhibitor, and I would take three of those a day, a roba clear.
That's our private label product, and I would take three of those a day.
I don't think you need to do another cheek swab test.
Now, if you haven't done a cheek swab test forever and ever, then that's another thing.
But if you've done a cheek swab test in the last six months,
and the only change that you're making is going off and asking,
I would just go on a roba clear three per day and call it good,
and we could do it on a cheek swab test after three or four months and see if anything's changed
to be able to offer that medication.